the family of a 10 month old girl who's
been on life support since she was born
won a small legal victory in a
heartbreaking battle to keep her alive a
judge in Texas ruled that Cook
Children's Medical Center cannot
disconnect Tinsley Lewis at least for
another three weeks
Tinsley was born with a rare heart
defect and doctors say she's suffering
and will never improve but her family
believes she does have a right to live
Janet shamlian is at the hospital in
Fort Worth Texas Janet good morning you
can understand where the family's coming
from here what are their next steps Toni
good morning this family isn't a waiting
game the judge granted the extension in
order to have more time for her to
consider the arguments on both sides and
Trinity Lewis is hoping against hope
that some other medical facility will
take her daughter despite the little
girl's condition which this hospital
says the toddler cannot recover from
still her mother is not giving up hope
she's made it before I know she gonna
continue to fight for her life Tinsley
Lewis's mom so she's relieved
a judge has extended her 10 month olds
chance at life at least a few more weeks
the girl has been a patient at Cook
Children's Medical Center in Fort Worth
since February born prematurely she was
diagnosed with Epstein's anomaly a rare
heart defect
what are your visits like with her I
spend the night up there all the time
I'm always there with her she knows me
she interacts with me everything doctors
at the Medical Center say Tinsley has no
chance of recovery or a normal life they
plan to remove her from life support
last month by invoking the state's 10
day rule the law allows a hospital to
stop treatment after 10 days if an
ethics committee agrees with the
hospital's decision and if no new health
care provider is found Cook Medical
Center says more than 20 hospitals have
declined to take Tinsley because they
agree she won't improve Cook Children's
and the care team have been devoted to
her since she has been at our Hospital
Winnie king with the hospital says
ongoing medical treatment is causing
Tinsley to suffer even the most basic
thing
it's changing her diaper giving her
medication doing treatments for her can
cause a medical crisis that will result
in intervention and results in more pain
and more suffering Tinsley's mother
disagrees saying she only wants what's
best for her daughter if I felt like she
was suffering I wouldn't be where I'm at
today fighting for her life for its part
the hospital says it's fine with the
judge delaying the decision until
January 2nd or earlier and it will
continue to care for the little girl in
the interim Michelle a tough situation
absolutely Janet thank you so much just
how can you make this decision yeah I
mean I totally understand friendly Louis
fighting for her daughter I really do
doctors can't be wrong they may not be
wrong in this case but they can be yeah
all right well Jana again we thank you